Hello, how are you? This is Jin with
Next Level Commander and today we have
another list of underrated cards. We've
done planeswalkers, we've done mana
rocks, and today we are doing vehicles.
Now, vehicles by its nature is very easy
to underrate because it falls firmly
into the category of traps for card
evaluation and how that works is when
you see a new card, it has a very strong
signal for what kind of decks it can go
into. My favorite example for this is
Generous Patron. Now, clearly this is
made for counter stacks, plus one plus
one counters, and minus one minus one
counters if you're thinking outside the
box. But, for a card this is both a
curse and a blessing. The blessing is
that whenever you think of a counter
stack, you think of Generous Patron.
Well, the curse is whenever you think of
Generous Patron, all you can think of is
a counter stack. But, in reality
Generous Patron is actually an excellent
choice for pretty much any creature
stack, whether it's ETB or recursion.
And I think vehicles as a whole kind of
suffers from this because clearly
Wizards is trying to make vehicles kind
of everywhere. Like, they want vehicles
in all kinds of strategies and
utilities. But, from our perspective,
vehicles is such a unique and strange
card type that I mean, they're they're
just vehicles, they go into vehicle
stacks. But, in reality they can do so
much more. One great example of this is
the Indomitable. Now, this is a really,
really good card, but it suffers from
the aforementioned trap, twice even.
Once because it's a vehicle and another
because it cares about pirates. As a
result, it sees the lowest amount of
play among all the Coastal Piracy
variants. So, today we are going to go
over 10 very underrated vehicles that
might just work really well in your
favorite EDH deck. Going from
underappreciated to criminally
underrated. We're starting with
Conqueror's Galleon. Now, this is a
classic from the original Ixalan. I'm
not sure how well it keeps up with the
power creep nowadays, but it's so unique
with what it does. It's a vehicle that
eventually flips into a land. It is a
bit slow and fiddly. You have to cast it
and the next turn crew and attack with
it. But, once you do, the payoff is
actually not bad, especially for decks
that are desperate for ramp. It becomes
a land and an excellent mana sink. I can
see this being decent in a control deck,
a deck that operates mostly at instant
speed, cuz once it flips, it's going to
stick around and generate value for rest
of the game. Next up, we have something
pretty spicy, the RMS Titanic. This
probably doesn't fit into a lot of
decks, but the ones that it does fit in,
it's a bomb. And it synergizes with a
lot of commanders. Of course, if it
works with artifacts or commanders that
can amplify damage, imagine this with
the new absorbing man and Titania.
That's 14 treasures or the good old
Jessica. Also, the new Ares, God of War,
he can crew and recur this pretty much
every turn. Or if a commander gives
haste, how about Alibou? Yeah, we have a
lot of options. And if we're doing
vehicles, we have to include Etherdrift.
And there are a few gems here. The first
one I want to talk about is Demonic
Junker. Once again, is the trap. Well,
you see this and it goes into artifact
decks. Sure, it does, but even in the
average deck, this effect is really
powerful. Even for seven mana, even if
you pay the full cost, it's a 4 for 1
killing three creatures and leaving
behind a vehicle to attack and block
with. But, are you really going to pay
the full cost? Probably not. How many
artifacts are there in your deck? If
you're not in green, you probably have a
decent amount of mana rocks. So, this
will cost four to five mana in most
cases. So, if your deck is in black and
it has some artifacts or even some
artifact energy, this should be
considered. Another one from Etherdrift
is Lumbering World Wagon. Now, the
Regalia is popular for a good reason,
but the World Wagon also is pretty
solid. What's great about this one is
the base being a three mana ramp and
grow. But, it does have a pretty high
ceiling being a consistent source of
ramp and potentially a large beater. I
want to evaluate this at somewhere
between cultivate and Sword of the
Animist. Both are staples in a large
chunk of decks. Now, if your commander
happens to be a five drop that you want
to cast early and has four or more
power, it seems like a good fit. Your
Pantlaza, Egra, Korvold, just to name a
few. Okay, next up, we have a new card,
the Vibranium Mining Mech. Now, I can't
say if it's underrated because there's
no data on it. It just came out, but I
feel like it's going to be overlooked.
It might go into some artifact decks,
and that's it. But, the way Vibranium
tokens are worded is actually
interesting. You can't cast non-artifact
spells,
but you can use them to to activate
abilities. So, if your deck or your
commander has some of those, this can do
a lot of work. And also, if you happen
to have a decent number of mana rocks,
the acceleration is very helpful. Keep
in mind, these tokens are probably
sticking around for rest of the game.
This card sticks out to me because I
have a Galazeth Prismari deck, and it's
just perfect in there. So, if your deck
also has ways to use mana aside from
casting spells, maybe consider this. For
number six, we have Forboding Steamboat.
Now, this one is played pretty much
nowhere, but it's actually not terrible.
It's a bit like a mix between Barter in
Blood and Grasp of Fate. It's an okay
effect, and the cost is not cheap, but
it's got a few little perks that for me
pushes it to be playable. Well, first of
all, like any competent edict effect, it
ignores tokens. So, you will most likely
get something good. And at the same
time, it's got this political
implication like Grasp of Fate does.
Sure, technically you're hurting
everyone, but there will be many
scenarios where only one opponent is
actively trying to blow this up. And
when you do get to attack, it's a
massive 5/7. You kill something for
good, and you get to investigate. And
when you kill that creature, maybe the
politics shift, and you can play around
with it. Maybe player A is holding off
blowing this up for until after you
process player B's Avacyn, but instead
you kill player A's commander, let's
say. Player A will be upset about it,
but they're definitely leaving the boat
alone. So, yeah, there's a lot of
interesting interplays here, whether
you're implicit or explicit with your
politics. And next up, this one is kind
of cheating cuz it's technically a
creature, but the vehicle side is super
relevant. Slicer, Hired Muscle and
Slicer, High-Speed Antagonist. If you
ever played the backside on turn three,
you know what it's like. If you want a
game where everybody starts at 30 life,
20 life, this is your boy. But, to be
fair, not every game is magical
Christmas lands. We're not getting this
in every opening hand, so the
responsible play is to have a deck that
can support this even in the late game.
The number one choice is, of course,
equipment decks. Going through Slicer's
EDH wreck, I don't see any equipment
commanders, no Cloud, no Syer Gwyn, but
you should really be considering him
because aside from the massive damage
you can do, imagine the triggers. Even
just a Sword of Fire and Ice, Slicer is
attacking four times per round. That's
four tri Oh, wait, did you forget about
double strike? I did. That's eight
triggers potentially. That's ridiculous.
Now, imagine this with the Buster Sword.
How about the Ether Spark? Yeah, enjoy
your 50 mana on turn five. Yeah, crazy
card. Okay, next up we have the
Belligerent. This is actually a very
strong commander. I imagine it's
probably pretty good in combo and storm
decks. How many legendary creatures
allow you to play from the top deck?
There's this and the the Reality Chip.
Yeah, that's a pretty unique ability and
very breakable. But, just in the average
deck, this is pretty good. I know a lot
of decks play Mystic Forge. If your deck
is not as combo-y and and more about
accumulating value, this ship can do a
pretty solid impression off the Forge.
And if your commander is able to crew
this without too much pressure, it will
attack for a lot, give you a treasure,
just value all around. It is at its best
in decks that have top deck manipulation
where you can shuffle or draw cards so
that you can reset the top of your deck
when you need to to get more value. And
after this, we have another new card
from Marvel and I I don't think people
will underrate this card, but I figure
I'd mention it just to be safe. Royal
Talent Fighter Jet. This card is very
pushed. Most of these effects, these X
cost token makers, they create these
tokens when they enter or when they
attack. But, this one does both. And the
vehicle itself is also a massive flying
threat. But, I guess it's a vehicle and
not a creature, so I guess they can push
it a little more. But, the tokens can
crew the vehicle. I mean, it's only crew
two, so this basically feeds itself. And
not just in token decks, either, in in
artifact decks cuz those have a lot of
flash enablers. You drop this at the end
of turn and attack with it, and your
opponents are on a clock. Also, decks
that are in red, they can give haste.
This is a massive board state out of
nowhere, you know, in Zirgo, Ishin, go
crazy. This is not even the best vehicle
for a token deck. I've saved what I
believe to be the most underrated
vehicle for last. Valer's Flagship. The
best kinds of token creation is always X
and at instant speed. Now, they've made
a bunch of pretty pushed options, but
this one still has its place. The
cycling ability is very similar to
Decree of Justice, and they share the
advantage of being instant speed,
drawing a card, and also very
importantly, they dodge conventional
counter spells. And for those perks, I
think paying two extra mana compared to
the base form is pretty reasonable. Now,
you will probably never not cycle it
because, yeah, the top side is not that
good of a card, but being an artifact is
pretty useful. So, first of all, it is
historic. That's relevant for a lot of
the synergies. And say if you're in a
token stack in white, you probably have
something like Enlightened Tutor, right?
That gets you a doubler, that gets you
ramp, pretty much any utility aside from
token makers. But now, you have that
covered as well. Also, any other tutor,
recursion effects, there's some synergy
there. And I'm not seeing this card
listed under any token commander, not
Marwyn, not Balin, not even mono-white
ones. Yeah, I think this deserves
another look. Okay, that is my list. Do
you have an unconventional vehicle you
enjoy playing? Did I miss anything? Let
me know. Ooh, and also, if you're
looking for sleeves, deck boxes, just
quality accessories, look up Kakapopo
TCG. Because I have an affiliate code
with them. If you use that, you get 5%
off. This is Chain with Next Level and
I'll see you in my next video.